e aí galera chega na altura vocês eu to
bem eu fui as olimpíadas eu fui eu fui x
olympya e fui eu fui mal [ __ ] para
começar essas olimpíadas atleta chegando
não tinha as com a feita às piscinas
secas falta na cerâmica o estatuto pela
paz e os quebra cabeça
a placa das vigas do estado está
chegando aí pô vai chegar daqui a pouco
ela está desembarcando a if deu certo e
foi bonito ver uma abertura com a
marilyn daquela coisa bacana explosão
cai milhão de pessoas para seu show de
wesley safadão aí o tema em abril os
jogos olímpicos ele disse assim eu
declaro aberto os jogos olímpicos seria
que foi o tema se fosse a dilma e assim
eu declaro aberta o veja bem os jogos
olímpicos é por causa do monte o livro
olhei preto
o livro 11 leio a gente o brasileiro
precisa dos restantes porque porque o
sport
o bote ou minha boca o rapaz alto embora
o é moreno alto bonito sensual só tem as
pernas finas as pernas do bode parece a
os galhos sexo de uma árvore qualquer o
homem mais rápido do mundo no que se
refere à questão de mais rápido do mundo
é o bonde é tão rápido que chegou antes
de construir assistam declaro aberto os
jogos ou as olimpíadas força marina
silva será sim é claro aperto chabu eu
me lembro de quando teve dengue nos
jogos escolares da minha escola não
atenta que fizemos de palha com pedaços
de vários de coco as vagas grande final
parecia nada do botnet gov
os funcionários e assim evitar a derrota
e os jogos muito duros com a calma calma
não vou bater mas vocês agora já sabe o
jogo normalmente acontece de plantação
não mandar botar todo mundo que pagar
com notas de 100 e vai receber o cantor
de barbada mt para poder bater bola a
comprou ciliar e produz 50 reais como é
que eu tô ba mec boa troca todo animado
antônio encontrou o tom de voz e
videochat ser vários jogos de negócio
tênis 6 é o jogo você tem que ficar
calado o sport quer que ele é meio assim
que tem que ter comportamento
dá para jogar tênis na escola primeira
rodada de bola como se fosse daqui essa
senhora e aí não se importava não
pretendem ficar com o analógico que vai
ficar aquela guerra falou que detém
maioria jogando tênis o cacique carlito
vê que ela repete o requisito é do irã à
aiea que é time metal head beque não
ripa de madeira não querem ficar com a
opel até o juiz do tênis geralmente é um
mac não fala não falou muito a vida e
benfica discutem neste país leva dino
thomas é nã deus que joga e ganha entrou
foi amável agora o jogo muito ruim disse
véu teles por causa das medidas que têm
a bola pega pá e tem que ter o replay
para ver se não vê é [ __ ] agora quer
saber qual o tênis que o valor da nike
não dá diz não quiser me down aceito mas
eu tenho de mesa tende mesmo a foto dele
mesmo acho foto que é sempre um asiático
que joga sempre é o japonês yushin de um
coreano aos mais o brasil também tem um
campeão mundial como é o nome dele
o goiano é muito massa pode prestar
atenção como é um jogo de tênis de mesa
e estou de bem quietinho 23 é muito [ __ ]
pode falar por um placar muito pouco é
tudo muito igual é a minha luta já
poderão tirar no par ou ímpar para ver
quem ganhou o jogo porque eu prefiro ter
elementos que têm essa emoção que eu não
gosto de tênis em jogar e tem tendência
a não gostar daquele que não sabia por
exemplo randy picchu é isso ele perde há
sete jogos já que paga para o dia do
ramo porque quem não pagasse o rani
porque não sabe joga valer como futebol
vôlei porque quem nasce já mesma no
útero é bater embaixadinha com a
placenta o que ele fez em do conseg
rápido pois é tem espelho ipi
entendimento está tendo o gosto único
tênis que consegue jogar na vida do
tempo do pole station jogo tendo para o
efeito
a teoria de que o texto por este não era
o momento é o jogo que é rápido demais e
o mundo fica em câmera lenta entendeu
ligado eo motivo fútil assistiu bolt
correndo assistir ao vivo eu vi ele de
perto ponte ele é um cara alto bonito
sorrisão oceania por onde você vê a
sinceridade no olhar de quem sabe que
nunca vai ser a mulher do pai a mãe do
boi pegar o chinelo falava bote não
corre não foi embora não chegar neles é
o pior ninguém corre há muito boa e acho
que é um tamanho do mundo que olhar pra
se falar se afastem graça semana esse
menino é tão ligeiro chegou do brasil
que é construída a vila olímpica ainda é
carne do salto mortal lá no negócio em
pine porque elas cor bonita não consigo
andar no meio fio sem cair até amanhã do
nado sincronizado que é formar de maio
em cima fica assim embaixo todo assim
ajudou também o pessoal derrubar essa
mesa do piauí sabe você é [ __ ] não deu
certo nessa olimpíada eu vi seu
sofrimento você tenta levar medalha não
deu certo vai da próxima com certeza vai
dar já trouxe muitas medalhas do piauí
tamo junto você vê o treinador na beira
do tatame vai você consegue
é isso que pegar mais pelo braço e jogar
por sinal pirueta calcular o pi forma de
boston e derruba eu não sei pra ser
treinado não fica na beira do tatame é
assim ea diana derrubou vai deixa a e
moleque bola eu soubesse eu tinha ido
luta' e tashi globo vida qishan vai
falar puxa roubar eu soubesse tinha
vindo este a que eu tive não eu salto em
distância também é uma modalidade que eu
acho mas que a pessoa sai correndo feito
8 metro canadá popular ump povo também o
cara bota o pé em cima da faixa branca e
como tipo 1 5 centímetro treinar e
cancela que não vai correndo o topo na
faixa branca passou de mal negócio ahmed
e aí não vale o velho cancelado no valo
salto no vazio imagina se o salto
valesse mas cada centímetro que você
passasse você queimasse é diminuir esse
teor desse tipo nas ruas cara polato
queimou 7cm diminui a 77 da rua do carro
negão duda se inscrevem na
na época o problema em casa que eu toco
tucano muito lá no negócio da mulher e
aí queria diminuir pelo menos 15 poder
ficar mais confortável é ficar ali os 25
sentimental tira aquele meu nome da
lista por favor vão aplicar a passar na
porta do estádio não quero mais falar
não vou fazer a playstation ea galera
falando isso cara se inscreva no site
distância de não não não não topou na
risca não se inscreve na boca é o nome
que não pela facilidade de ser não ser
pela modelo queimada e sem tinta e
acabou pra mim eu quem deve sentir bem
vou ter que ficar pastel com os caras lá
fora pode estar na prova foi a sensação
maravilhosa eu assisti ao jogo do brasil
eu vim marta eu vi neymar neymar volnei
mais sou fã do neymar cara vai eu falo
que quiser nem mais tem aqui você pode
falar tudo que quiser neymar neymar sabe
jogar bola nem mulherzinha moleque gosto
de gente que joga no le caixa o pessoal
reclama comigo no twitter e fique
tentado esconder o jogo é só o rapaz do
brasil perdendo fazendo piada no twitter
eu digo não fui convocado eu sou opção
do blog esporte mesmo sendo gordinha
assim eu gosto de esporte acho legal
esse negócio de jogar dardos cara eu
gostei muito das olimpíadas a isso aí se
você gostou deste vídeo já sabe fazer
clique gostei aqui no youtube bota lá no
facebook obteve novo jogos olímpicos
dólar a clique em curtir no facebook
marca seus amigos lá embaixo que vão se
interessar por assistir a um gol desse
vídeo aqui comenta aqui embaixo no
youtube com o sport lá dos jogos
olímpicos e gosta mais que você gosta a
maioria assiste se a um futebol sério da
luz era o salto com na vara vai sair
muito obrigado até a próxima se inscreve
no canal para não perder nenhum vídeo
novo ai eu é na ideia